hello guys welcome to this video on the
top 5 future programming languages by
simply learn
today we shall be listing the future
programming languages and getting to
know each
one by one before getting into the video
here's a gentle reminder to subscribe to
our channel and hit the bell icon so
that you wouldn't miss any update from
us
programming languages have changed all
our lives taking us to a whole new world
it has made applications easier to use
and more efficient
with various developer communities and
different use cases emerging there are
numerous new programming languages
coming up
and the common question among beginners
is which programming language should i
learn
with the ever-growing list of
programming languages making it really
tough for programmers to pick any one
language
we are here with the list of the top
future programming languages for the
coders who want to make it big in the
coming years
note that these programming languages
are in no particular order
so let's get started first we have
kotlin
kotlin developed by jetbrains is a
cross-platform open source statistically
typed programming language
one of the stated goals of kotlin is to
compile as quickly as java
similar to how java was named after the
indonesian island java
kotlin is named after kotlin island near
saint petersburg
kotlin version 1.0 was released in
february 2016 and in november 2017
kotlin version 1.1 was released google
has fully supported kotlin designing
android apps as an alternative to java
since october 2017.
kotlin can be used for web development
android development windows development
as well as site application servers it
runs on java virtual machine
and is much simpler than java kotlin is
an easy to learn and one of the fastest
growing programming languages in recent
years
it is indeed a wise choice for android
app developers and programmers to learn
this language in the coming years
here's a snapshot of kotlin programming
language
next on our list is swift released in
2014 swift is a compiled programming
language developed by apple and the open
source community
inspired by python swift is simple safe
and easy to read and learn
this programming language was developed
as a replacement for objective c
apple's earlier programming language as
swift made the code quicker to write and
less prone to common errors
it quickly gained in popularity
particularly with the ios developers
the specifications of this language are
quite broad and it's just not as
syntactic objective c
cleanup one of the killer features of
swift is its language design
it has a simpler concise and clean
syntax
as a compiled language swift is as fast
as c plus plus
according to the stack overflow survey
this programming language is ranked
sixth as the most beloved programming
language
with people becoming more addicted to
their cell phones at all hours of the
day
the need for ios developers and
programming languages like these isn't
going away anytime soon
here's how a code snippet from swift
looks like
next on our list is go designed by
google go is a statistically typed
compiled programming language
it was designed back in 2007 to improve
programming productivity in an era of
multi-core
large code bases and networked machines
it was publicly announced in november
2009.
go is widely used in production at
google and various other organizations
and open source projects
it has excellent built-in support for
concurrent programming which makes it
best for highly complex applications
due to its syntax go is considered as an
easy to learn programming language
it does not incorporate any complicated
concepts or complex meta programming
it's best suitable for minimal web
applications apis and web servers
also according to a recent survey of
tech professionals golang programmers
had the highest average salary of 132
000 uh dollars per year
all these pointers are enough by itself
to state why you should learn this
programming language in the coming years
this is how a simple go program looks
like
next on our list is typescript developed
and maintained by microsoft this
programming language is a strict
syntactical superset of javascript
and adds optional static typing to the
language
this was first made public in october
2012 after two years of internal
development at microsoft
several it experts have recognized the
popularity of typescript which is
considered as ideal for developing large
applications
like go and kotlin in the list the key
feature of the typescript is the
language design
it has crisp and clean code which makes
it one of the most elegant programming
languages out there
typescript is one of the fastest growing
web programming languages
it is ranked fifth according to github
octoverse
so if you're looking to learn a web
programming language typescript is a
good choice
here's a snapshot of typescript
programming language
and finally next on our list is r
r is an analysis programming language
that is used for graphical and
statistical analysis of huge data
this is an open source analytical
environment which helps in data mining
and data representation
it is supported by the r foundation of
statistical computing
and was implemented in 1976 at bell labs
r comes with a set of inbuilt wide range
of libraries that are useful in
statistical and graphical analysis of
chunks of data
our programming's primitive
implementation is written in c
c plus plus fortran and r most of the
extended user defined packages are
written using these languages
which specialize in statistical
techniques
this makes our expandable language for
various platforms
so here's how a code snippet from r
looks like
and there you go that's our list of the
top five future programming languages
think we missed any let us know in the
comment section below
we'll be back again with yet hi there if
you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch
similar videos turn it up and get
certified click here